stan always said that the marvel
universe is the world outside your
window
and that the people can find characters
they could see themselves in
[Music]
bringing a piece of art to life is
difficult to not put yourself into
the work
[Music]
we were artistic rebels
i can't even imagine the impact that pad
better take off your shoes because i'm
going to knock your socks off would love
that yeah
people really believe women weren't
reading comics that inspired us
to do more cosplay
is the visible expression of one's
fandom
nobody else had ever done this before
fearless storytellers i killed spiderman
what that's insane
the marvel spotlight program is a
collection of stage plays
written for high school i
never thought i could make a living
drawing
the japanese spiderman is totally
different from the original spiderman
we're living in the golden age of toys
superheroes connect us
it's one big epic story
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and today marvel released their
marvel
616 official trailer now this is
actually going to be
a very exciting new series coming to
disney plus and hopefully a very
impactful one to our community marvel
616
is going to be about how comic book
characters and of course comic books
influenced people in their real lives so
the show is essentially about
our community it's about us and i'll
break down what exactly we're going to
see
in this new disney plus series including
what to expect from each
episode and this is confirmed to be
eight episodes long
so to start off with its title it's kind
of funny because they call it marvel
616.
now in the comics earth 616 is the main
marvel universe where everything really
takes place but it's also used to show
the marvel universe's place inside of a
larger universe a multiverse which is
what this show is about
what marvel's place is in our world so
episode 1
is quite possibly going to be one of the
coolest episodes ever
it's going to be about japanese
spider-man
this is something that not a lot of
people may have heard of before or even
seen in 1978 marvel struck a deal with
japanese tv giant tui to adapt the
company's most popular superhero for
japanese audiences
now this spider-man is something that
we've never really seen before here in
the us
it involved a really giant robot a
really cool car but most importantly it
became a really important influence on
japanese pop culture and this first
episode is going to tell the story and
show
footage of japanese spider-man that
probably a lot of people haven't seen
before
the second episode is titled higher
further faster and it's going to be
directed by gillian jacobs from
the show community that the russo
brothers directed and it's going to
introduce the viewers to women who have
played important roles in marvel's
history
the third episode is titled amazing
artisans and it's going to focus on two
international marvel artists
javier garonne and natasha bustos who
live in barcelona and use their life
experiences to influence their work
on popular young superheroes like miles
morales and moon girl
episode 4 is titled lost and found and
this is going to be kind of an
interesting episode because they're
going to explore the most
obscure the most wild and forgotten
marvel characters
the fifth episode is actually pretty
cool it's titled suit up and it's going
to be
about cosplay specifically it's going to
be about
interviews with cosplayers and people
who are attending new york comic con for
the very first time
so if you're wondering what new york
comic con is like or you're trying to
get your taste of it since it's been
canceled this year
this episode is for you yes nycc is
still online but you can't go to it and
walk around and dress up like you
normally do
episode six is titled unboxed and is
actually going to go over the
relationship between comics and toys
and they're going to explore when and
how sometimes toys influence the comics
and comics influence the toys
and a lot of you will like this they'll
be going over marvel funko pops
episode 7 is titled the marvel method
and it's going to take a close look at
the creation of the new
iron man 2020 comic they're also going
to show us the historical background and
development on the marvel method
as it was created by stan lee and jack
kirby and the last episode the eighth
episode is titled marvel spotlight now
it's interesting because this
is going to be directed by alison brie
so as it turns out she was meeting with
marvel about a project it just wasn't
she-hulk but it's going to follow a
group of students at florida's
brandon high school as they put on a
performance of the new marvel spotlight
plays and they'll talk about just how
much the marvel characters mean to them
and influence them in everyday life
and that's what we're going to get from
this new series no it's not a series
connected to the mcu but it's a real
life series
it's about how marvel affects us our
community so it's going to be a pretty
cool show
i'm definitely watching it and i hope
everybody else enjoys it as well
this comes out on december 20th on
disney plus so let me know in the
comments down below if you were going to
be watching it
of course i'm still doing my funko pop
giveaway this week we're giving away a
cyclops funko pop all you got to do to
enter a subscribe like this video and
leave a comment down below
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof